und wird es feierlich der zeitpunkt ist
gekommen
wir erheben uns alle von den plätzen ja
auch sie zuhause liebe zuschauer
wiederum einfachen haben kam zu einer
neuen folge drei cocktails
ich höre nichts merkt aber ich sehe
etwas etwas was so wunderschön ist wie
einen sonnenuntergang in vietnam mit
einem glas champagner in der hand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich spiele
aber heute sehe ich nicht für ihn ein
ganz anderer mensch ich würde so mit
einigen fehlern und youtube zeit war so
rumlaufen
[Musik]
ich bin ein pauli spirit und das ist
wenig übertreiben du bist der schiri
heute drei männer meine meine liebste
schwester barbara hat ja gesagt bitte
nicht schließen auch nicht die augen
schafften abdecken das ist auch schon
schnee von turin
ich mache so ich lese euch heute aus
meiner heiligen bibel vor denn heute ist
das thema karneval definition wie wir
heute auch die piste ich war nie
irgendwas machen ich weiß nicht was man
dazu sagt auch im gespräch
mehr
draußen ist schon morgens schwört dass
ihr brave mädchen sein werde
und heute gesund nach hause kommt im
geiste des vaters der immer bei euch da
ist kommt so was hat die bibel für euch
gesorgt
[Musik]
borriello drama play bürger das ist
leben
hannah placement dicker dass es leben
die patches zu deinem outfit sagen was
in der hitze einen sitz weil sie wissen
die bibel und machen daraus endlich
sonntag danke gott
extra für die ein bisschen an die küste
nutzen
[Gelächter]
thema ist heute natürlich karneval und
unsere aufgabe war es unser kostüm das
ist wirklich eine art stein
kann mich nun ändern ich brauche schon
betrunken ist und deswegen machen
reisekosten cocktail also wir müssen
unser kostüm in einem cocktail packen
dafür waren wir natürlich stolz was mich
ein ich weiß nicht mehr stellen uns
unsere zutaten vor ich finde kelly
darauf anfangen weil sie hat so lange
gewartet wir kommen so machst das was du
denkst dass sich eva lia warum müssen
gewinnen klar muss man sagen okay ich
hab gekauft für mein schiedsrichter
outfit war schnell los da kirche zitrone
heiß
[Musik]
ich habe nur für mama
[Gelächter]
eigentlich lebt mal haben und da habe
ich hier noch billig in körperlich solch
eine story zu erzählen
früher habe ich in einem restaurant
gearbeitet die haben berlins verkaufen
wir das aber verkauft oder so eine
eigenmarke vorher als creme die tollsten
für deinen restaurant wenigen das mache
ich nicht in meinem laden einlagen wird
nur top kollektiv verkauft außer ich
werde mich nicht ob kohle und
traubensaft und mit schrauben und gurken
müssen sich die nonnen ernährung
[Musik]
vorgabe die sind wir natürlich alle hier
und spielst und basilikum aber das
interessiert mich nicht mehr
morgen wollen jetzt mein liebling das
sagen mögen mögen die durch spiele
können
[Musik]
und jedes mal heimlich gemacht
schokosoße sagen keine ahnung
[Applaus]
okay und ich mache jetzt erstmal zwei
[Musik]
bestimmte deko na ja ich weiß aber ich
musste noch ein bisschen mehr wie komme
ich klar kellys schoko so eigentlich
müsste das eine karamellsoße seien aber
wieder und kg improvisieren dafür
brauchen die zuschauer auch war ja
habe ich mir ja ich habe neue zutaten
sondern das was meine oma früher und
cafés
bis 18
ohne schokolade deutschen ballern geld
der fahrer tritt sicher mal und war
nicht vergessen sie auch ein junger
skater
berlin
ja
natürlich natürlich geplant
das ist gut glauben
[Musik]
ja so ein bisschen kaffee chocolate kopf
dass er so qualität dieser produktion
ich bin fertig leute ich auch was hier
rammte ist so hübsch geworden so schnell
fertig ich bin wenigstens so kreativ
heute reißen und kreativ langsame
crusade das sind eigentlich dass ein
bisschen länger braucht deswegen sie
mich aber stellt das sport weggefahren
können gibt sich richtig mühe und ananas
und bürger und sei dann ein paar wollte
ich eigentlich noch tragen aber braucht
man glaube ich nicht danken
dort war schwer
beträge horizon das ist auf
zimmertemperatur betreuen
ich denke einfach also die leicht
missratenen marshmallows mit dem fall
nicht wagen stand weiß schwarz sollen
eigentlich stimmt hier darstellt und
eine süße kombination zudem sehr
fruchtigen drinks darstellt natürlich
haben wir den dreck aus gelb und rot
symbolisiert der gelben und der roten
karte des schiedsrichters
die rolle sei gut drin wodka und sei
derzeit haben damit gab es geht unter
unter die ganzen geschenke es so
schlecht gemacht die anderen anbieter
und scharf und ich bin zimmertemperatur
zu füllen sie gleich ab ohne sich darin
hat sich euch sagen das machen wir so
ein geheimnis
okay mein cocktail ist ein holy spirit
cocktail sieht man an dem kreuz team
konnte aber ich hab's lecker beschrieben
oder dafür gibt es punkte für die ja dem
april-wert mit dem gelb unruhig
dabei ist es faszinierend jahren da bin
ich auch einmal darüber richten
so kurz vor komplimente gefüllt zu mir
und dann aus dem snack zu karneval auch
sehr schön back office word und die
katholische kirche das kreuz
symbolisiert meine oma von der ich meine
religiöse art ab die jetzt aber leider
und damit auch mal eine user und denke
ich nur so von apple so das ist das
hollywood all das ist das ist der der
arzt dem der vogel bei noah mitgebracht
um zu zeigen dass wieder land gibt die
schicken doch da steht man hier stehen
lassen wir doch diesen beiden weißen
punkt mit dem ast
das ist weil die dann bin ich auch bei
pokémon jetzt kommt der twist weil die
damit schon alle ein böser ich bin eine
böse sondern ich bin ja keine guten
und das und das ist das ist saft vom
apfel ausgaben eben von dem eva gegessen
hat
weil er bei der jesus wasser zu wein
gemacht hat sich seit ihr wieder von mir
die tour wird auch sinnliches auto
geister irgendwie ich das gerade
wirklich auch das wichtigste element so
intensiv ist das ist nicht gut ist der
bass
[Applaus]
zuvor müssen wir heilige oblagen blätter
und legen also muss ich von meinem
screen schmeckt man sich mit traurig mit
nach wodka ja ja alles was man gemacht
das wort ganz so frisch und ist sehr
leicht also man hatte eher das gefühl
den 110 zu tun als dabei ist es am
echten sundermann stadt hat da kann
das räumt zuschauer zumindest traurig
dass du deiner firma cocktails schmecken
das volk wieder in münchen eigentlich an
das ist gewaltig positiv ist oder waren
nicht übertreibt natürlich übertrieben
natürlich überzeugt von den leuten sehr
zutraulich und die story dahinter story
über iconic und der geschmackssinn basic
und häkelt so manche was hast du gemacht
also ich hab es aber sein very very
sorry dass ich meine ich bin so richtig
zu hause so sahen sich wie das meer aber
ich denke die ganze zeit zum himmel aber
der himmel blickt nicht zurück
das ist ein ganz experience natürlich
ich habe heute kein klassischer erkennt
da ist so musste ja eigentlich karamell
sein aber es passt aussuchen kann ich
habe ich hier an im rennen dann ganz
viel sowie salz drauf bewegung und der
sinn ist dass ihr erstmal
und dann
berlin das ist so ja so recht passt
nicht so richtig geil aber auch so
dafür aber probiert mal warum apple care
[Musik]
also erstmal weg
aber dieses ja dieses salzige milchige
belize geschmack ja ich glaube schon
dass sich vorher hat aber sein dass von
einem kostüm zu tun meinte ließ konnte
die ganz so kritisch und mit der gedanke
okay sagen auf 3 wo wir glauben wer
gewonnen hat
die glauben 133
warum bist du so gemein
warum bist du dort wieder leicht
ich hab so ein tag ist so alle
anstrengungen die kennen wir schon
die alle und falls ihr jetzt sky news
release besser aus wie jetzt gibt es
derzeit und ich wünsche euch einen
wunderschönen tag und hoffe ich war ja
auch gerade weil wenn nicht dann hoffe
ich war ja die falsche wenn nicht dann
viel spaß in meinem leben und die kamera
liebe nicht das würdet ihr sagen ich
sage die kamera lief nicht machen besser